the jurogan experience have
any of the people that were initially
skeptical or pushing back against the
idea that it came from
this level four lab are they coming
around or are they still digging their
heels in
so some are are coming around and um
so certainly there are people like like
matt ridley who's a member of the house
of lords in the
in the uk a kind of very well-known
science communicator
he was firmly on the other side and now
he started to be
more open and actually has been quite uh
quite vocal
what was his motivation for being on the
other side did he yeah i think that in
the beg
it's a really interesting story because
in the earliest days of the pandemic
there was a concerted
effort by a relatively small number of
high-profile
scientists virologists who recognized
that if the story was that this came
from a series of what are called
zoonotic jumps between
animal hosts in the wild that was going
to lead to kind of a
positive outcome where we'd say hey
let's be very mindful of our
encroachment into wild spaces climate
change all those things that we should
be very mindful of
but they were i think probably worried
that if this
story became dominant of an accidental
lab leak i mean that would have huge
implications for all of the research
that people are doing and a lot of it is
is very well intentioned so early last
year
there was a process where a series of
scientists did two things one
they came out with a letter in the in
the british medical journal the lancet
which we've subsequently learned was
highly manipulated by a small number of
people who may have had vested interests
and there was a
academic paper in a journal called
nature communications and both
made the case oh this isn't a lab leak
and then there was a concerted effort
to label anybody else as a conspiracy
theorist and so i kind of spent
last year in that uncomfortable space i
mean i'm i
i don't live my life as a conspiracy
theorist i try to be data-driven in
everything that i do
but i really felt that this was a very
real
possibility and it deserved a full
investigation and it was
only in the beginning of this year uh
2021
that that started to turn i know i had
i wrote some things uh someone named
nicholson baker he had a great piece in
new york
magazine um the wall street journal did
a great job
um covering this and so this the space
was starting to
to open up then they had that really
in my mind ill-fated press event in
wuhan where it was this
independent committee and the chinese
government and they said
don't investigate lab leak investigate
the frozen food
hypothesis and then in every newspaper
around the world
the headline was the world health
organization
says don't lab leak is not is not
possible essentially and so i
immediately sent messages to my my
friends
at the world health organization and
saying look you're this is being
misreported
the world health organization hasn't
said this
and the the position of the who
must be we have to investigate all
hypotheses
and i was very pleased that three days
later so the press event was on a
tuesday that friday
tedros adenom who's the director general
he then
said in a press event that we believe
that every
hypothesis needs to be investigated
which implicitly
meant the lab leak hypothesis and then
our letter
uh came out which was just uh just last
week i mean it feels
it's been such a whirlwind since then
and that's been picked up in
newspapers all around the world so now i
feel like there
is an opening and i hope that we can
continue and the goal
in my mind isn't to prove like i don't i
don't feel like i need to
maybe if it's provable i'd love to prove
it but it's not to prove that right this
point
that it is a lab leak or isn't but we at
least need to have
the most thorough unrestricted
unpoliticized investigation into what
happened
with access to all the lab records all
the samples there
there's tons of scientists in china who
were working
on these issues very very few of them
have been interviewed we don't have
access to them and frankly i think a lot
of them are afraid that if they speak up
they'll be imprisoned or worse yeah that
is the problem right
the the people that were initially very
vocal
um and biased
towards the idea that it wasn't a lab
leak and you said they were highly
motivated and
they labeled other folks a conspiracy
theorist what
what was motivating them yeah so this
it's a really
tricky point and and so there's been a
lot of
controversy i got around a guy named
peter dayzak
and peter is an interesting figure
because if you had asked me
uh a year ago a year and a half ago who
are the people who you respect
most in the field of virology
he would be really at the top of my list
he was one of the heroes
of understanding where the first sars
came from he has an organization called
eco health alliance that was really
trying to get
ahead of the curve on understanding
these these pathogens
but he also through eco health alliance
was a funder
of the wuhan institute of virology
specifically
the gain of function research that was
being done there and i i
truly believe it wasn't anything
nefarious it was the idea was well if
we want to understand dangerous
pathogens we have to do it
in the place where those dangerous
pathogens are
then under the obama administration
there was a moratorium on this kind of
of gain of function research um and then
it was lifted
in the trump administration so that's
one one
piece of it and so for peter i
understand that his whole
experience of his life has been well
this is where
these kinds of outbreaks come from um
and but this could be just a very
different story and for me personally
that's i think one of the reasons why i
was able to see this a little
earlier perhaps than other people is
that you know part of a big chunk of my
life has been in the world of science
but another big chunk of my life has
been in the world of understanding china
and so i think if you're just in the
world of science you don't understand
china you think well the chinese
government
says that this isn't from a lab leak it
must not be from a lab leak but i know
that in the chinese government they've
totally suppressed the entire
basically history of mao and all the
millions of people who died under mao
when they got their speed trains uh
going the first train had this terrible
crash
and they just buried the whole train and
and pretended like it it never happened
until there was an outcry and they had
to they had to to dig it up so i
i feel like i understood a little bit
more about the pathology of the
of the chinese government so but coming
back i think there were people
in the kind of more traditional virology
world
who felt like we're going to open up a
whole can of worms
if we say well maybe it was a zoonotic
jump
and maybe it was it was elaborate so
this one guy
and his influence shaped the way the
entire world was addressing
this outbreak i wouldn't say it's one
guy but it was
i think a relatively small number of
people
because they certainly that the the
lancet
letter and it was all kinds of big
luminaries
who signed it that really shaped things
um and so definitely if if the story
in the beginning had been maybe this
comes from a zoonotic jump
maybe it comes from a lab leak we need
to look at
both options or i think that would have
been a much healthier place because
there would have been more
pressure on china so it wasn't just one
guy but peter
certainly was was very influential and
then
in spite of this conflict of interest
he's
actually was selected as a member of
this world health organization
independent advisory committee so one of
the the
people who went on this mission to china
was peter he also
is the chairman of the lancet this same
british journal that i mentioned they
have a study
study group he's the chairman of that
and i'm not saying he's
doing anything wrong i'm just saying if
you have that kind of conflict of
interest
you shouldn't be in those kinds of roles
it's just always so disturbing to
someone like me who's a non-scientist
who relies on scientists
to be unbiased and to just look at the
data
when you find out that things are being
influenced by very
human factors like ego
and financial gain and relationships
with
foreign powers and laboratories that
they're involved with and
that scares the [ __ ] out of me well you
know this better than most anybody joe
because you kind of are here every day
looking into people's
psyche and people are people even even
scientists and
everybody in the world has a story that
explains what they're doing and and why
and so i'm sure that you
could maybe even should have peter on
the show and he'll give you
his his story but at least from the
outside
looking in the way i would see it is
well he's he's
invested his entire life into doing the
right thing
trying to protect us from this terrible
threat of a
pathogenic outbreak he correctly
recognizes
that encroachment into wild areas and
climate change are big threats wherever
wherever covid
ii uh wherever covert 19 stars 2 comes
from still those are
are good things to do he has a
long-standing
relationship with the wuhan institute of
virology and a friendship
with the people who who who work there
and so you you can see how we cut my
guess
and you know i can't speak for him he's
become kind of a stakeholder in this
story but we shouldn't
this isn't just about peter i mean there
are lots
of very prominent scientists i would say
there are more prominent scientists
who believe that this comes from a
series of zoonotic
jumps through intermediate animal hosts
in the wild then there are
who believe that it's more likely to
come from a lab leak but what i will say
i get a lot i'm in touch with
lots of people who are world famous
scientists scientists who
many many people will know who are
privately telling me
we think that there's a 90 chance that
it comes from a lab
but really don't want to speak up
because we don't want to get pulled into
the muck
you were talking about trump before
people remember the iraq war
where there were all kinds of experts
who were saying oh they definitely have
nuclear weapons and then
we invaded the country it's like oh oops
they don't have it so people didn't want
it to justify any kind of bad things and
as scientists i mean the problem is the
the scientists rely on data
and there wasn't data because china was
was covering it up
and the the the journalists require
scientists
to make to legitimate claims about the
origins and so there was
this weird thing that's that's lasted
for
a year and our hope is and we're
starting to see that our letter
has opened up some space where we can
have a real honest conversation about
let's let's
look deeply into all the possibilities
and try to get to the right answer
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience